the best part honestly of making icarly
is when little kids come up and their
faces are just in shock and they're so
excited
that's a then 12 year old miranda
cosgrove aka carly shea with our cameras
on the set of icarly in 2010 and again
in 2011 the year the cast earned their
third consecutive emmy nomination for
outstanding children's program the crazy
part of it is that um a lot of people
will come up sometimes so it'll kind of
be like a mom of people excited about
the show and that's when i really start
to think wow like so many people watch
it and are into it it's really cool sir
you have to let her leave we're doing
icarly tomorrow night a what it's a
popular web show
it can't be that popular if i've never
heard of it over its six seasons icarly
earned a total of seven emmy nods
turning miranda and co-star jeannette
mccurdy into bonafide child stars so
first we want to say thanks thanks
hey spence how was your date last night
nearly 10 years after its last episode
icarly gained new life with a paramount
plus reboot in 2021 when i started the
first show i was 13 years old and most
of the experiences and things my
character was going through on the show
were things i was going through in real
life and now i just turned 28 and eye
character is going through all the
things you go through in your late 20s
so it's just been really fun getting to
play the character again and getting to
see where her life has taken her
noticeably missing jeanette aka sam
puckett
sam
excuse me i have to turn my back on you
now
sam
i know you love brad it's exciting okay
did you like fall out of a tree or what
we all really wanted jeannette to be a
part of the show in real life but um
she's just doing other things and we're
really happy for turns out the 30 year
old quit acting years ago after feeling
embarrassed by her past roles i'm
focusing on on what i choose to focus on
you know i'm focusing on writing and
projects that feel authentic to me and
that align with my mental health
but she writes in her memoir i'm glad my
mom died that her sisterhood with
miranda has been a source of camaraderie
and emotional support i'm friends with
the rest of the cast too she says but my
connection with miranda is different and
special
it did provide me a lot of comfort in
those really challenging years my
relationship with miranda was hugely
healing to my concept of women and my
mom was always saying
men will never really know you and
they'll hurt you but women will know you
deeply and then they'll hurt you you
tell me which is worse and i have three
brothers who i love and i felt this sort
of trust toward
boys that i didn't feel toward girls of
course very young
and miranda helped me to heal that
relationship
jeanette shared similar feelings to e.t
this past august revealing where she and
miranda stand today oh my god i love
miranda to pieces i always will she has
such a special place in my heart she
helped me grow as a person and heal as a
person and i hope i did the same for her
and i just love her so much
[Music]